you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news
on today's programme the government's
grand plan for reducing emissions from
planes trains and automobiles is
published
find out what the future looks like for
how we get around
a warning the amazon rainforest could be
starting to emit
more carbon dioxide than it absorbs
and kicking off a summer of
sustainability on sky sports
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and meet those coming up with the
solutions and the government says it's
the world's
first green print an ambitious plan to
decarbonize
all forms of domestic transport by 2050.
the critics argue the proposals are
unrealistic
underfunded and the technology to meet
the targets doesn't exist yet
today the uk's transport decarbonisation
plan was published
our climate correspondent hannah thomas
peter has all the details on what it
will mean
for how we move around green energy it's
it's our future yeah we can't rely on
coal
anymore or diesels
thomas has been driving trucks for a
decade he knows that transport is the
uk's largest contributor to emissions
and agrees that needs to change but as
part of its drive to decarbonize the
sector
the government has announced there'll be
no new diesel hgv
sold after 2040 a big change
at an uncertain time the plan has left
an industry
still grappling with hydrogen and
electricity as alternatives
feeling adrift this proposal is
unrealistic alternative hgvs
don't yet exist we don't know when
they'll exist
and we don't know how much they'll cost
and it's not clear what any
transition will look like
trucking isn't the only industry
affected by new targets
the department for transport is also
pledging to get domestic aviation
carbon emissions down to net zero by
2040
that's ten years earlier than previously
promised
but the decarbonization of our world
isn't straight
forward and when it comes to planes for
example the technology used to make them
greener
is still very much in development and
it's expensive
in fact money seems to be the key issue
here the government criticized for
producing policy
without a plan yet to help pay for it
unless we see action now from the
treasury
and from richie sunak the decarbonising
transport plan and any plan on climate
that comes over the coming weeks won't
deliver what it needs to
that may be true but this roadmap
contains
a series of big gambles that the markets
consumers technology and the
government's own purse string holders
will all deliver as we march towards net
zero
hannah thomas peter sky news heathrow
in today's other climate news nasa has
warned the moon's
wobbly orbit around earth could impact
global coastlines
because the moon's gravity pulls the
ocean's tides towards it
this wobble set to start by 2035
will cause higher tides and higher sea
levels
combined with rising sea levels caused
by climate change some countries will
see a dramatic
increase in flooding the european union
has unveiled
new laws to help meet its target to cut
greenhouse gas emissions by 55 percent
before the end of the decade a dozen
major proposals
include phasing out the sale of petrol
cars and plans to tax the carbon
emissions generated by goods imported
from foreign countries
it's now down to the 27 member countries
and eu parliament
to agree to the proposals and singapore
has built one of the world's
largest floating solar panel farms
spanning an area the size of 45 football
fields the panels will produce enough
electricity to power the island's five
water treatment plants
the solar farm will reduce carbon
emissions by about 32
000 tons every year the equivalent to 7
000 cars being taken off the roads
now here on our data dashboard you can
see the total amount of carbon dioxide
the world has produced in million tons
it's ticking up the whole time as fossil
fuels such as coal
oil and gas are burned now the world has
long relied on the amazon
to help absorb some of these emissions
but now researchers are warning
the rainforest's ability to act as the
earth's lungs
could be changing well our science
correspondent thomas moore
is here to explain why thomas global
warming
would be a whole lot worse if it wasn't
for the world's plants
sucking up carbon dioxide since 1960
they've absorbed around
a quarter of all fossil fuel emissions
and the amazon has been a big part of
that
it contains an estimated 123 billion
tons of carbon
but new research shows the amazon basin
is in trouble
in the west it's absorbing slightly more
carbon than is being released from dead
rotting trees and human impact
but in the south and the east which
accounts for more than a quarter of the
amazon area it's become
a net source of carbon so how's that
happened
well the amazon gets more than two
meters of rain
on average every year between a quarter
and a third of that results from
moisture
that's released by trees but the
amazon's climate is changing
particularly in the east over the last
40 years
rainfall at times of the year has
decreased by up to a third
and temperatures have increased by up to
two and a half degrees
now the scientists say there is a clear
link with deforestation
in the east around a quarter of the
amazon has been cleared
mostly for agriculture more than twice
as much as the west
the fires used to clear the forest
release huge amounts of carbon but the
absence of trees also
dries out the surrounding forest raising
the risk of
more fires as well as stunting the
growth of the remaining trees and
reducing carbon uptake
it could be the beginning of a major
tipping point where in just a few
decades
much of the forest dies that would
shrink the habitat of unique species
and accelerate global warming thomas
thank you
now free public transport and a scheme
to help households switch to green
alternatives
could help make the transition to a net
zero future fairer for everyone
now that's according to the
environmental justice commission which
wants people to be put
at the heart of the government's climate
targets their findings were informed by
four citizens juries who suggested
changes they thought would help them go
green
the biggest barrier is our lifestyle
is cost i think the biggest thing all
around was
obviously education when i joined the
panel
i knew very little about it it was a
pretty big eye opener to me
those of us who are our jurors on the
program could act as colombia champions
in our neighborhood in the local areas
so we could then pass the message on to
the local communities our demands
fuel what is produced why do we operate
like this
can we do it differently we are going
against
years and years of conditioning
people have over the years developed
habits
fast fashion fast foods fast everything
there should be more information out
there
for people to to realize what's going on
there's a need to
engage with the local communities a bit
more
well luke murphy is the head of the
environmental justice commission and
joins me now
so your report says that people and
fairness need to be put at the heart of
the drive to hit net zero so what does
that mean and how can it be achieved
well firstly i mean we know that action
on the climate and nature crises
is urgent the question now is really
about how we carry out that transition
and the crucial message of the report
today that we launched today
is the opportunity to improve people's
quality of life
there's a real opportunity to do that
through this transition in creating new
jobs improving health and well-being
and tackling poverty but what we heard
from people and communities right across
the country
was that this transition must be rooted
in fairness because unless it is rooted
in fairness
it simply won't succeed because the
public support for the transition
simply won't be there and the government
has set out its strategy for for zero
carbon transport does that
meet your brief of putting people in
fairness first
i don't think it does i mean we
obviously welcome some of the measures
it's it
has some ambitious proposals in terms of
uh an earlier phase out
of petrol and diesel vehicles and it's a
particular focus on trucks
but i think what we've called for and
actually what we heard from
citizens across the country from south
wales valleys
was that they want to see much greater
investment in affordable
accessible public transport they want to
see greater investment
in active transport in walking and
cycling and that really was missing from
the government's strategy today lots of
targets lots of lofty ambitions
but i'm not sure there's really enough
to deliver the kind of change
that actually the kind of the the people
want to see across the country
and you've listened to people as you say
up and down the land do you think that
the public should play a greater
role in formulating climate-related
policies
absolutely that's something we we heard
again and again
people want three things they want more
information they think
actually there should be a kind of uh an
information campaign similar to covid
that recognizes the scale of the threat
of climate change and the scale of the
change that we need to
undertake secondly they want to be more
involved in decisions themselves they
want to see
more things like juries that go beyond
just
the normal consultation and thirdly they
want to see more powers
devolved and given away from westminster
uh or the devolved governments to their
local areas to their local councils
no plan um we can't have
one-size-fits-all
plans that's what we were told and so we
need to see powers distributed across
the country
to allow local areas to develop their
own plans
luke murphy thank you thank you
now this summer sky sports is
highlighting the impact of climate
change at some of the uk's highest
profile sporting events
ahead of the cop 26 summit in glasgow in
november
and to kick it all off sky sports news
presenter david garrido
has hit the road in an electric car of
course
right stop one hot's the way tottenham's
training ground we're here with club
ambassador deadly king
you're top of the sustainability premier
league table why should fans care
climate change is something that is
affecting us all when it's failed that
we will do our part
as we are doing here at the club okay
listen lads i'd love to chat and stay up
for breakfast but we're on an electric
road trip let's go
stop two is the overall we are talking
the first ever prototype bamboo cricket
bat ben is the co-inventor talk to me
about this ben
so it captures more conductors than a
willow cricket bat it's grown next to
the factories so we save on transport
missions
and it's got a better end of life than a
willow cricket bat
stop three is dorney lake i'm here with
some gb rowers the 1992 champion greg
sterl
and melissa wilson as well melissa i've
been hearing about this as a symbol as a
gesture what does that mean exactly
yeah we're creating a green legacy for
team gb this summer and part of that is
involving athletes too
so we've got them doing this symbol it's
the olympic rings it's planet earth it's
the need to get to carbon zero and
you'll be seeing it on your screens this
well that's everything from us for today
coming up tomorrow the people
forced from their homes by extreme
weather events becoming more common
and more frequent because of climate
change you can see that here at the same
time on sky news
thanks for watching see you then